it's tempting to look at divinity
original sin and call it a throwback to
the days of baldur's gate and Planescape
torment a time that many role players
still look back on with much fondness
original sin may have the trappings of
such a game the isometric camera
perspective an adventuring party of four
magic spells and pubs to relax in and
all manner of RPG staples but this game
is very much its own and a fantastic
fantasy journey in its own right full of
tents turn-based battles grand Wizards
and clever spots of humor and
self-deprecation read nearly identical
to a man's the volume of the blood can
cause quite a mess as you could imagine
so we're careful to perform the
sacrifice within our specialized
chambers only these chambers are
designed not only to collect wayward
fluids but also to muffle any unsavory
noises produced by defiant lost ones
original sin gets off to a slow start
which can prove a little frustrating in
the early hours when you traipse about
the first town learning the ins and outs
of the game systems the introductory
dungeon and an array of tooltips teach
you the basics but there are still
common genre conventions you must learn
to live without such as waypoints and
automated crafting interfaces this is
your chance to explore to test the
waters and to poke and prod at the game
to discover what makes it tick in the
process you discover that original sin
forces you to confront the consequences
of your actions and does so in ways that
most RPGs that boast meaningful
decisions fail to match you cannot take
every loaf of bread from an inn or open
any door you please lest your actions
lead to disapproval from the homeowner
or even the wrath of nearby guards
original sin goes even further however
to the point where you must consider
every action for instance digging up a
grave in front of a grieving widow
causes her to attack you in her grief
this one simple action should you not
think it through might lead to an
innocence death and all for a measly
bone as a
reward when this happened to me I felt
more guilty and more invested than I
have felt in entire quest lines in other
choice driven role-playing games and so
you learned that every action has a
reaction that you must read recipe books
and refer to those recipes later if you
want to make a club out of a piece of
wood and a handful of nails you craft
items by dropping and dragging objects
onto each other directly in your
interface window or perhaps by dragging
items onto a nearby furnace the
excitement of new and gorgeous places to
explore is often matched by the joy of
learning how to make something new and
useful from a book or just discovering a
new recipe by experimenting in your
inventory you spend a lot of time in
your inventory windows which proves
rather cumbersome after a while but
there's that special moment when you
create a magical starfish by accident
and then you work to figure out what
exactly you can do with a magical
starfish what a wonderful place this is
to be brimming with terrific characters
that have heartbreaking and sometimes
crazy stories to share there's a
skeleton who misses having a soul and
you might convince him to replace his
head there's a statue that promises to
show you how your journey ends and roles
the games end credits if you ask to see
your future
there are blizzards and dust storms to
trudge through their spider worshippers
and cultists and an otherworldly place
to call home
every discovery is a thrill depending on
how you play that might mean the thrill
of working out how to solve the quest at
hand it might mean the thrill of talking
your way out of conflict using original
sins cool rock paper scissors
conversation system or it might mean the
thrill of doing battle with
necromancer's that see through your
attempts to charm your way out of a
fight such battles are tense and
thoughtful once you're engaged time
pauses and combatants enter battle
stands from here your party members
perform whatever actions you command of
them until you use up their action
points or end their turn while you start
with skills from specific classes of
magic and melee and so forth
character progression is very flexible
and thus there are plenty of ways to
turn the tide of battle the greatest
interplay here is that between the
elements
you can create a rainstorm and then cast
lightning spells to zap and paralyze
anyone standing in a puddle including
your comrades clouds of poison can be
ignited and oil slicks can be set a
flame as you level up you can earn
talents that further alter combat such
as one that allows you to heal when
standing in blood some battles are
rather challenging but pay careful
attention to the elements and spend
skill points smartly and you can
overcome I haven't mentioned a number of
original sins minor flaws a few bugs
some fiddly micromanagement switches
that are hard to see a clumsy stealth
sequence and so forth but I also haven't
mentioned so many of the game's wondrous
surprises dungeons that spring new kinds
of traps on you and have you once again
reconsidering how you must think about
traveling through this mysterious world
great writing that flushes out
characters and a few sentences without
turning them into OneNote cliches I
can't describe it all here all I can do
is ask for your trust when I tell you
that divinity original sin is a special
role-playing game and playing it is to
fall in love with our PGS
all over again
you